herzlich kommt eine neue folge ich fahre
leute heute sind wir in köln und fahren
ddt 63 s 4g wieder hinter der kamera ist
es nicht etwas gebe was ist ernst
gemeint oder zwei unter können wir man
mag's leider krank ist leider nicht da
ist aber der gardine mal um deinen wagen
der zentren zitiert
[Musik]
beide elemente auf
djg steht für
unfassbar
das dienen
[Musik]
hat ein aktionär 639 psm.etr gemacht ich
glaube ich bin noch nicht hundert so
beschleunigt wir sind hier auch direkt
frisch aus der wäsche haben haben wir
hinten drauf
315 erreichen 21 zoll dieser york also
findet fest verbauten finde ich schön
aber das hier ist so loki weißt du wenn
du willst einfach eine sache die fed
dazu ein das ist nicht deine wave aber
es gab viele porsche fahrer die auf
ihrem ausfahrbaren spoiler also
komplette guck was drinliegt
ganz wichtig
verwirrten serienmörder oder sowas ja
aber diese auspuffblenden aber wartet
immer rein ja okay es ein fake doppel
bin ich weiß übersät leute aber da geht
nur ein rohr aus 13
aber wir kennen die mit großen wohnhaus
auf die fresse fliegt mit dem
ortseingang dieser dreh so viel anders
als jeder andere weil wir so viel
scheiße labern also klar dass es im
grunde wird und so können aber auch ein
sehr sehr schwarzer wagen hinten
sitzheizung vorne massagesitze und sowas
wäre ich den wagen wenn du erste mal
gesehen habe
heraus kamen dachte ich muss und dann
ist karbon leisten und so was hier
weihnacht ist herbst also ich find
keinem auto gerne gehen so entspannt ist
einfach geil war in seiner jugend
dankeschön erdiger ordentlich alexia
muss man auch sagen die erste frage in
dem format ist immer
was bedeutet es für dich eigentlich wenn
also das klingt super dumm wenn man so
eine karre fährt für mich erst mal das
auto für mich ist freiheit und
fortbewegung nein also gefühls ja sind
job von a nach b kommen halt safenet
aber wenn man das klingt jetzt dumm aber
wenn man die möglichkeit hat nice von a
nach b zu kommen dann kann man sich das
schunkeln
also was was du nicht sagen willst du
bist so reich dass es sogar für die
themen die der scheißegal sind viel geld
ausgibt dann versteht das hoffen wir
doch nein also wenn ich erst mal lockt
jährlich bin so ich glaube das auto ist
meine persönliche teuerste auf ausgabe
nix bei der wohnung alles andere als
dass ich auch teils geschäft ist so weil
ich erst mal die geschäftliche fahren
damit haben aber ich glaube das ist mein
größter persönlicher luxus ja
tatsächlich ja ok verstehe ich ja erst
und du bist ja auch sonst also du lebst
hier in relation zu deinem einkommen
wirklich sehr loki muss man sagen ist
also ja ich weiss nicht irgendwie das
was ich mache ja sowieso wenig im urlaub
klar aber war vorher nicht derjenige der
sich dann englischen luxusreisen wieder
ein bisschen mal klamotten und sowas
natürlich würde ich sagen dass ich
komplett gar nichts aus gebe ja aber so
was wie uhren und so ist und das ist
nicht mein sohn weiß also genau man muss
auch dazu sagen leute ich werde auch
gleich noch das ist ganz wichtig pro
tank mit sprit geld geben wir uns werden
überall her genauso habe ich mit anderen
aber ich würde lieber aral alter mit
zwei das sagen wollte also wir beide
kennen sie jetzt auch schon ein paar
jahre
ich kann die male nicht mehr zählen an
dem du mich dafür verarscht dass ich
meine rolle geholt habt also du lebst
relativ loki muss man schon sagen dein
sexuelle fetische sind halt immobilien
so geil wenn ich wenn ich so eine geile
hausfassade mit
let's go
[Musik]
bis 4000
geil der junge und das ist ja ein
absolut neues auto oder dass die neue
autos doch können ja ja aber ich glaube
es wird weniger werden das wird so wenig
zuwendung zu hopsen ich weiß was ich und
der klingt natürlich ganz anders und ich
hatten sich vorher gefahren
hat auch mit ganz anderen sound gehabt
weniger als erstes aber es gibt
natürlich gesetzlichkeiten an die
sicherheiten stellen muss wird das sorgt
also ich bin ehrlich ein sound in der
wagen ist kalt und so wichtig finde ich
wie ein auto klingt und wie sich das
gehört alles mit dazu aber natürlich
kann hier ein stück weit so verstehen
dass halten jeder nachts um drei von den
kranken auto geweckt werden möchte wenn
er wirklich so dass in der großstadt dem
ich wohne ja in köln leute hat mich
jetzt auch dazu geführt dass ich sogar
wenn leute mich krass abschneiden mit
die vorfahrt nehmen ich nicht mehr hub
in der stadt
es gibt nur noch lichthupe auch wenn
leute an der ampel fahren ist einfach
auf respekt damit die leute nicht
plötzlich wenn ich lernte war krass auf
jeden fall dass das fühlt sich irgendwie
bewältigt war an das auto beim lenken
ist es ja auch ist es noch übels
bewältigbar ich sage es so wie es ist
ich habe den wagen noch nie topspeed
ausgefahren
topspeed bei dem auto bei 320 oder sowas
ja aber das muss ja
wie hast du übrigens natürlich versuchen
dahinter es ist einiges drin ja es ist
natürlich schon spaßig so man muss
natürlich aufpassen es gibt halt ganz
viele leute die dann immer so auf
straßenrennen mäßig ankommen okay einen
beten wollen aber gehe ich halt
niederbrennen so also ich finde ich halt
affig so gerade hier in köln gefährlich
größere hatte ich meine gerade hier in
kärnten bei gefährlich aber auf der
anderen seite so warum musst du auch
eine ampel kickdown des todes geben und
losbrettern weißt du was ich meine so
das ding ist wenn du so ein auto erfasst
und neben ihr steht ein ford focus rs
und der will nicht herausfordern du
weißt ja dass du gewinnst ja das klingt
ja dumm aber das musst du dir nicht
zeigen
verstehst du was ich meine so lasst ihn
fahren dass unser ding machen so aber
warum solltest du dann führerschein und
das leben von anderen leuten gefährden
so deshalb also ich glaube so auf der
rennstrecke ist der wagen ja anders wird
das muss ich auf jeden fall aber mache
das muss ich hab vorher natürlich
abklären und so aber kann ich mir sehr
gut vorstellen und kann ich mir sehr gut
vorstellen egal ich mache mir ganz kurz
mal die sitzbelüftung anja nicht durch
die massage reinhauen
ich hatte auch mal eine kopie
das hat er auch
ich habe gesehen was für ein schiff das
ist heute nicht vaters und es geht um
die kurve die hose sowie das fähig als
krass der wagen es möglich lang breit
und schwer aber der fährt sicherheit
nicht so da hat mercedes new york ein
meisterwerk der technik ausgebaut
vorstellen
du fährst dann wirklich eine limousine
aber der fährt sich nicht wieder
limousine und das das krasse den wagen
kannst du sehr schön sportlich und wenn
du möchtest du kannst du darauf auf
komfort kannst du ihn sehr bequem sehr
sehr ruhig fahren weißt du was ich meine
du machst dir tempomat rhein autobahn
140 nur dass sowas oder 150 auf ganz
entspannt fährst du denn da einfach und
dann bist du am ziel weißt du was ich
meine es ist sehr sehr sehr angenehm ist
ein sehr schönes gefühl
naja als 6 139 ps
also man ist schon ausreichend
motorisiert hat es nur für den
stadtverkehr absolut das reicht das also
dass auch so eine sache
würde ich jetzt wirklich nicht mehr
lange strecken fahren und so so ein auto
in der stadt parkplatzsuche das schöne
ist der hat dieses aktive
hinterradlenkung des jahres die
hinterachse lenkt mit leute geht ein
bisschen mit nicht so natürlich wie die
fordere aber dass sehr sehr krasser so 8
grad und wann ich hab das genau ich habe
schon sehr auf gehabt dass leute so den
kopf schütteln werde jede parklücke
sagen nein kein fall richtig einfach
durch ein paar kleinen die gucken mich
auch noch fragen
was bist du von gott im endeffekt habe
ich 300 kameras haben und seine hinter
hat sie die mitte nicht lenken das ist
ein schöner fleck server damit einparken
kann obwohl es eigentlich ja gut also
heißt jetzt nicht dass ich dann gut auto
fahren kann
aber das natürlich eine große hilfe aber
wenn du jetzt mal unter uns sind so in
der stadt braucht man zur not ja ja es
wird das braucht man irgendwo hoffe aber
das kann halt alles ja ja alles leute
ich habe hier eine massage ich kann 320
fernsehen kann von 0 auf 100 in 3,9
sekunden die das auto kann alles er
platz für vier leute wurde sogar für
fünf leute machen ich habe aber für die
konsole entschieden
ich finde die leute einfach und
entspannt hat der wagen sollte der kann
wirklich alles ist ein praktikables auto
wie gesagt er kann alles außer günstig
sein das kann halt nicht das ist halt
dass ich eine sache also da muss man
auch nicht so das kann man doch nicht
beschädigen so das ist auch das einzige
was nicht persönlich so ein bisschen
immer nachdenklich stimmt ist muss ich
ein auto fahren was so viel verbraucht
nicht finanziell gesehen ja primär so
der umweltaspekt ja und das ist immer so
ein bisschen schwierig aber auch da
wieder für die motorisierung die der
wagen hat ist er tatsächlich aber ist er
verbraucht aber er kann ja sogar aus dem
stadtverkehr meisten sport plus modus
bin sowieso gerade ist ja ein
vierzylinder modus stellt
zylinderabschaltung zylinderabschaltung
wenn ich den 90 auf der autobahn fahren
möchte komme ich auch mit acht litern
nach berlin
traurigkeit 80 aber ja es geht halt
alles geil digger ist will ich eine sehr
schöne lösung das interieur ist
wunderschön ambilight ist mit trainer
das schöne tacho ja vorne was einmal
durchgehend des heads up display und so
es ist wirklich ein ja ist einfach
einzigartig schönes auto kann man nicht
anders sagen wo man kommt auch züge von
der ampel weg
genau also jetzt auf der gerade eben ein
bisschen hoch beschleunigen aber alles
im rahmen natürlich ausnahme ist
randvoll ist ein bisschen drüber arbeit
und hier aber jetzt auf der autobahn
können wir ein bisschen einigungs spur
ganz einfachen grund
[Musik]
das ding ist so ich sage es mal so wir
drücken natürlich jetzt nicht mehr voll
verkehr immer komplett durch und sohn
ich kann sich aber aus erfahrung sagen
also zum beispiel wenn ich halt nach
zwei freie fahrt haben sondern sehr
angenehm also die beschleunigung ist
sehr brachial muss wirklich sagen der
sound ist geil ein v8 natürlich auch
einfach hier wieder leute angeht übrig
oh ja okay okay okay okay da geht mal
kurz ganz kurz liter mal rein in die
tour größe dann
[Musik]
das ist jetzt schon also hier ist tempo
denn 20 und 100 auf 120 herstellen
kein kommentar zu erhalten wird es noch
einen gang höher gesten ende
genauso
geil
das frisch
ich bin mitten im feierabendverkehr
deswegen sind ungünstig entwickelt sich
so viel machen aber ich glaube so also
die könnt ihr gar nicht vorstellen zu
diesen wagen genau stellt den wagen
einfach vor schluss schaut euch das
video auch schön sein aber wieso man
will jetzt hat er nichts
der schaltvorgang dabei sein kann der
bass und gesang wird die sehr schönes
auto
der sound der anlagen muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen
der wagen hat eine akustik an sich die
sehr sehr sehr schönes sie gesagt ich
war hinter sich meistens sondern
durchgehend vor der ganzen stadt er hat
schöne akustik der sich laut auf der
autobahn ist eine schöne anlage also
hier natürlich auch tunnel hat natürlich
ist ein geschlossener raum oder weniger
heißt die schreie reflektion ist ein
bisschen größer
geil
sehr dankbar und ist immer etwas sagt
immer wieder etwas besonderes ist jetzt
so ein fahrzeug zu steigen und so liebe
ist man ja man hat das hat nicht gegen
die so erwartet das hat wirklich damit
gerechnet dass irgendwann mal an einem
punkt im leben ist man so was halt als
als alltag bezeichnen könnte was du ja
krass
du hast sicher hoch gehandelt ich sage
es immer wieder also ganz klar das thema
bescheiden es immer wichtig man sollte
jetzt nicht denken man steht über
anderen menschen oft gar keine da es
noch defizite weil das halt aktiv
mattews deswegen aber also man sollte
ich denke dass wir über einer leuten
steht aber dann ist ja eigentlich auch
gut so man muss sich jetzt nicht
schlecht fielen dafür dass man halt mal
was leisten kann auf keinen fall halten
können dann kommen wir zu bewerten leute
und die beginnt wie immer mit der
kategorie aussehen leute schaut euch
dieses auto an das ist einfach eine
wucht ich komme hier nicht umhin 9 von
10 punkten zu geben service niveau wie
zum beispiel der porsche von luca oder
auch der lambo von imax einfach ein
wunderschönes auto zu kommt bei mir doch
dass ich auch coupé limousine wie den a7
zb auch einfache liege also neun von
zehn ganz klarer fall die beschleunigung
ist im besten sinne des wortes hart an
der grenze 3,0 ich habe es gab noch mal
nachgeschaut sekunden von 0 auf 100 sind
einfach eine wucht da ich aber gesagt
habe dass es nur für werte unter drei
sekunden also weniger als drei sekunden
10 von 10 gibt gebe ich hier eine neun
von zehn aber wie gesagt es ist quasi
eine 10 14 coolen ist schwierig leute
eigentlich hätte ich ja auch eine neue
von zehn gegeben aber das große aber bei
der ganzen sache ist dass mercedes
wirklich mittlerweile so krass weit
verbreitet ist in deutschland das man
bei vielen modellen gar nicht mehr so
diesen um ein gott moment hat so hatte
man da habe ich noch nie gesehen gerade
wenn man in einer großstadt wohnt wie
ich in köln sieht man diese autos schon
öfter dafür muss ich in meinem
persönlichen kunden empfinden punkt
abziehen auf acht von zehn die
praktikabilität leute ist aber unfassbar
für ein auto mit diesen fahrleistung
wirklich unfassbar wenn man hinten die
drei sitze hat kann man wahrscheinlich
mit fünf leuten ohne probleme in urlaub
fahren man hat noch ordentlich platz für
gepäck hinten im kofferraum klar der
verbraucher bisschen hoch aber das auto
ist schon wirklich praktisches preis
leistungsverhältnis dagegen ist mal
wieder spielleute eigentlich hätte ich
gerne sieben von zehn gegeben weil das
auto wirklich einfach die eierlegende
wollmilchsau ist auch wenn es fast eine
viertel million euro kostet
das kann einfach alles eben außer
günstig seien aufgrund des preises muss
man hier aber einfach noch ein punkt
abziehen weil das wäre uns wirklich
einfach eine banane sechs von zehn der
komfort ist genau so unfassbar für sein
schnelles auto wies die praktikabilität
schon war leute ich erinnere die
e-klasse von max und mia e-450 coupé hat
beim komfort acht von zehn bekommen und
ich dabei ist beim gt 63 ist ja okay ist
auch e-klasse plattform ist natürlich
bisschen härter als das e coupé muss
eigentlich punkt abzugeben also sieben
von zehn aber diese ganzen features
leute massage sitzbelüftung ich kacke
wirklich ist es zu krass acht von zehn
muss damit kommen wir insgesamt auf eine
spitzenposition mit 48 von 60 punkten
leute waren sind dieses auto wird es
noch nicht eine viertel million euro
kosten lassen wir gern aber dabei ich
das hier gefallen hat heute ich freue
mich auf den nächsten sonntag bis dahin
muss gut